sage au pied des pyrénées
comment ce coupé l'année 94 des affaires
de bourcagneux avec nos envoyés spéciaux
crypte et du plan charmante petite
bourgade de notre région bourcagneux sur
glaire située aux confins de la hanche
et de la glère peut s'enorgueillir de
ses 352 habitants et habitantes qui
vivent dans l'harmonie et l'entente
exceptionnellement les élus de cette
charmante bourgade ont accepté la
présence des caméras de la télévision
française pour filmer une séance
restreinte du conseil municipal dallas
stars pour cette histoire que je leur
dise qu'il a ajouté lafarge et ronny yu
dans les airs jusqu'aux élections ne
seront pas jalouses n'est pas moi
peut-être que le produit mais je suis
une merde pour moi ici à bourcagneux
quelques semaines de doute je suis un
peu le père de tous et je veux un
consensus à bourcagneux alors sommes
heureuses ancien milieu et le consensus
est plutôt ton fils week que tu elle
avait quand même vers attendre bull à
fond poli avec nenê je te prier parce
qu'a ta femme sally a pas fait l'oeil de
temps corner jolie oui bon mais ça c'est
des histoires de loups qui n'intéresse
pas nos amis d'edf trois ans à droite un
chaudron au patin droit et moi tu n'as
rien et l'embauché de l'homme témoin
mais je suis le fait le village a pas
d'avoir sauté roulades et encore heureux
nos mémoires non mais c'est vrai quoi et
alors je peux être accusé de tout le
mouvement d'eau sous prétexte qu'il alla
sable qui a de gros besoins mais il ya
un proverbe qui dit faute et a couru son
jardin ça me va oui c'est la sagesse et
l'inria
à présent je pense qu'ils s'en matane de
parler un petit peu de gestion communale
rien comme tous les petits villages
bourcagneux sur glaire reconnaissait
bonheur de ses peines ici comme partout
l'économie rurale et rennes sans
bourcagneux la production régionale de
maïssa devrait pas les sommets que l'on
nous envie de partout à l'ordre du jour
de ce conseil municipal le problème
épineux des communications villageoise
petites routes des chemins qui font la
joie de nos campagnes de résultats
la voirie durant la campagne électorale
est un premier faire un grand poids dans
le village et oui en quoi tu le sais
comme moi
de nos jours tout comme unis qui se
respecte à dos rond point voire même à
la race de faire boire la drac ce petit
portable non c'est vrai qu'à la taxe ne
peut rond-point de toute beauté
il tombe bien pleines mieux dans l'autre
et ce qui fait le plus joli c'est que le
studio mire un rocher nombreux caïds et
en 400 meilleurs salaires a coûté 400
millions d'euros et on la cherche à
gibraltar ou par là mais non ils se sont
endettés à gaza jusqu'à le premier 2006
c'est pas dans la gestion à 3026 gauche
et tu le gagnes et les promeneurs sa
paire paraît aussi du préfet saisira de
table par le crédit agricole et renan
non je vais les pauvres parce que on ne
peut pas faire en 3d rend boivent comme
ça à tout bout de champ 1 il y avait moi
pour faire des ronds points
tu te lèves papy boom tu fais ton bon
ami non sinon on irait elle pour faire
boire un vase
il ya des lois c'est obligé il faut au
moins 2 kg est deux c'est la vraie
question c'est la loi mais plus doazit
tu es le show de pareilles football même
type et tout va sortir pour la deuxième
ronde
tu peux me dire et pour venir ou et
pourra réunir la question la question du
caillou est réglé
il n'y a pas que le travail et soucis
dans la vie des habitants et habitantes
de bourcagneux sur glaire bugs à nourrir
du magnifique terrain baptisé du nom du
regretté amédée la moulière car pour ces
gens de la terre le dépassement physique
le jeu de rugby aussi qu une véritable
tradition du coeur et de l'esprit comme
la pelouse du panneau du reste bel et
bien le cas s'il vous plaît un peu moins
tel laxisme et donc j'achète est le
changement reste là pour faire le
complexe gymnastique aux sportifs
je ne pouvais pas savoir que c'était une
ancienne voie romaine sa note du groupe
par le savoir donc le moment de lancer
c'est pourquoi la valve de le vieux-mans
fermera pas te plaindre fait caca procès
marcaillou là et puis la femme peut
jouir ont le droit de courir comme ça de
fouler la mosaïque c'est joli tous deux
en espagne où il ya des caveaux la rampe
est en tout cas c'est aussi jolie que tu
es ligne de touche la tête occupe sa
place à paris et le palais me ressortir
un jour ou l'autre ça que tu le sais
comme moi qu'on n'y peut rien c'est le
vieux resta qui nous tracer les lignes
ça fait 30 ans que le fait qu'on peut
parler de sortir et tu le sais que c'est
difficile car entre copines hier
c'est des réseaux le petit cimetière
opérer un arbitre d'image emilio moyens
oui le drapeau comme ça au risque de
tonnes il s'arrête en revenir le type
excuse moi ça fait pas champion
[Musique]
l'auteur ne
de solides amitiés une franche
camaraderie unis nous l'avons vu les
élus de bourcagneux un véritable exemple
pour nos enfants
amour sport gaieté joies simples de la
france rurale
[Musique]